hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video today we're gonna be back on for
tonight again and we're going to be
talking about a guide and tips and all
that stuff lejana
handle on how to use the pistols in the
game and that being the pistol it's a
press pistol hand cannon and revolvers
so let's get started so first off
personally to meet pistols are some of
the most underrated guns in fort night I
know that sounds kind of weird but think
about it pistols have every single
rarity in the game grey green blue
purple and gold and they do some decent
damage and they can even one-shot people
depending on the weapon you're using but
like usual for today's video we're gonna
be going over the damage stats of each
pistol some strategies for each pistol
when and when not to use them and
finally give my overall thoughts on each
weapon by comparing them to their
substitute counterparts we're gonna be
splitting this into two groups the first
one is the pistol and suppressed pistol
then the revolver and the hand cane and
the second one technically these are
both pistols of course even though they
take medium and heavy bullets as to not
bore you with the length of this video
if you do want to skip to the revolver
and hand cannon part of that searcher
here for you can go to the time stamp on
screen for that if you do want to watch
the whole video now let's get started I
also want to mention I'll be doing
guides for the assault rifle shotgun an
SMG as well and how to get the most
materials fast in terms of harvesting
materials quickly in fortnight so if you
guys definitely want to see those and
subscribe for the other for those videos
in the future other than that let's get
onto it so first up is the pistol and
suppressed pistol the regular pistol
comes in gray green and blue rarity
while the suppressed pistol is in purple
and gold the damage ranges from 23 to 28
for a body shot depending on the rarity
for headshots I have managed to do
roughly forty to sixty obviously
depending on the rarity that is used the
mag size is sixteen all across the board
giving you tons of both to lay into
someone for strategies I like using
pistols in the beginning of matches
since they are plentiful on floor loot
especially in the beginning of the game
if you have a nasty trigger finger you
will excel with these two weapons they
do two decent damage and combining that
with a fast fire rate for your trigger
finger you can melt enemies almost
instantly my speed isn't bad but it's
definitely not garbage it just takes a
lot of practice to shoot fast as well
and to aim on your target I'd rather
shoot slower and hit the target every
single time then spray and hope
something lands but that's just based on
your sensitivity and accuracy which
something you the player have to improve
on yourself a quick tip to be using
these pistols a lot is to get used to
them people have probably said this
before but practice makes perfect and
it's definitely very true the more you
practice on shooting
while aiming the more skill you will
develop from it making you a better
player while continuing on if you're
lucky at a suppressed pistol early game
I'm myself and mostly set for the rest
of the game obviously getting a shotgun
Med's assault rifle of course are
necessary but in terms of pistols I'm
mostly set up for the game I usually
prefer to use the suppressed pistol
sifted silent and allows me to shoot
fast at my target while doing some
decent damage as well seeing as the
suppressed pistol does about 26 to 28
seeing as obviously is purple and gold
rarity you obviously want to pick up the
suppressed pistol over the regular
pistol since it is silent does more
damage and has overall better stats for
Destruction wise unless it's your only
option I would stray away from
destroying traps and materials with it
it takes too long requires about a clip
and a half to destroy a trap put some
materials which is a waste of time and
ammo the suppressed pistol and regular
pistol are amazing for rushing someone
if you don't have a shotgun on hand or
your early game trying to clear your
landing zone like example trying to
clear a building and tilt it or any
building for that matter since you have
since even if you miss a few shots you
still have at least 10 more bullets in
your clip left like we stated numerous
times these weapons go off your fire
rate so you can pump out good damage
very fast if you're quick and accurate
enough for strategies you want to pair
these two weapons with a sniper or
shotgun or even the other two weapons
revolver and hand cannon you can use the
other weapon as your main damage source
then clean them up as you can spray with
the pistol to finish them off you want
to use the pistol in close quarters
combat or medium range the pistol at
longer ranges is pretty useless and not
worth it since you could just use an
assault rifle and be more efficient that
way it's also nice for ramp rushing as
well if you don't have a shotgun since
you're going to be close quarters the
whole fight you could also use it if
you're on the receiving end of a ramp
brush and the person is closed allowing
you to get in some quick easy damage
while they're trying to build up to you
you don't want to use these weapons
though at long range like we said before
they don't have very good accuracy at
long range and at that point it's a
waste of ammo firing from that far when
you can use a sniper rifle or assault
rifle is way more efficient for my
overall thoughts I feel the suppressed
pistol is better than the normal system
for obvious reasons but if you're close
then use a shotgun and then if you're in
medium range using a are that's my only
issue with these two guns though and
it's probably why most players don't
pick these two weapons up a lot seeing
as there's way better options to have in
your loadout depending on the situation
you're on but continuing and moving on
we have the revolver and the hand cannon
these two weapons require more accuracy
than the pistols since it's not based on
fire and more on aim and skill the
Rarity's are just like the others the
revolver comes in great green and blue
well the hand cannon is is purple and
gold the damage could range from 50 to
60 on a body shot for the revolver and
about 70 for a hand cannon the headshots
is where this weapon shines though the
revolver and hand cannon can get about
140 plus damage for one headshot which
will kill most players in the match for
destruction you can definitely use these
weapons on materials and traps to
destroy them but if we using the heavy
cannon though do be aware you are
wasting heavy bullets which may or may
not have a surplus of depending on the
stage of the game you're on if you're in
the early game then you're probably not
going to have a lot of heavy bullets but
if you're late in the game you'll
probably have a lot more than in the
early stages so it's entirely on your
situation for strategies these should be
your main damage sources compared to the
original pistols we talked about where
those are the clean up weapons these
weapons should be used to start a fight
if your accuracy is on point you can
easily eliminate or knock down a person
early into the fight and gain the upper
advantage since as stated before these
guns can do about 140 damage to the head
or 50 to 70 to the body depending on the
rarity you're using if you find the hand
cannon in early game keep it and save it
unless you need to use it the only
reason is because the hand cannon takes
heavy bullets and there usually isn't
much at the start like I said before all
this do happen to get lucky so try to
use the revolver early game since mo is
more plentiful then stick with the hand
cannon towards the end since there
should be more ammo by then for when to
use these two weapons they're the
opposite of the previous two these
weapons should be used in medium to long
range combat only obviously if it's
early game and that's all you got then
you have no other choice but to use them
but these guns do a lot of damage and
could be used at long ranges compared to
the pistol since they have way better
accuracy if you're trying to pick
someone off from your base or from a
distance this is absolutely viable
especially if you have the high ground
you can also use this if someone is
trying to ramp rush you since most of
the time they're trying to build stairs
running upwards which makes them an easy
target since they normally like to go in
a straight line and are focused on other
things you can pop them in the head real
quick and clean them out super easy for
one not to use these weapons it's close
range combat it's more beneficial to one
pump someone or spray with their other
two pistols then use these weapons
my opinion since you have to wait to
fire every time and not to use a trigger
finger like the pistol and suppressed
pistol now that being said if your aim
is god-tier you can and you can one tap
everyone by all means use that revolver
hand cannon up close but for most of us
that's not normally the case for my
overall thoughts though both of these
weapons are great would it be better to
use a sniper than the hand cannon yes
but if you don't have a sniper and it's
a pretty good substitute the revolver is
really nice early in the mid game but I
would recommend the hand cannon over the
revolver entirely especially in the late
game since you're going to have a lot
more ammo and it does a lot more damage
let me know what you guys think about
the weapons and the comments down below
and as always if you have any tips I
didn't mention that are worth noting
also leave that in the comments below to
help out other players in the community
but that being said that's going to be
the end of the video like I said in the
beginning I have other guided videos
coming with SMG assault rifle shotgun
and even harvesting materials the
fastest so definitely stay tuned for
those like the video if you did enjoy it
really does help me out I appreciate you
guys watching some of my fortnight
content subscribe if you're new I'm
starting to cover these guides like I
mentioned in the at just a second ago
and at the beginning of the video that
I'm going to be doing those guys in the
weapons and I'm gonna be doing other
tips to make people better players as
well as covering the future content like
the heavy shock and I just did recently
and any other future stuff coming to the
game my two most recent videos are gonna
be on screen if you guys want to check
those out I believe one of them is the
heavy shotgun guide so if you're having
a little bit of trouble on that might as
well hop over and watch the video I'd
really appreciate it but that guys hope
you have a great rest your day and peace
out